OVER.
GOES JUST WIDE FRONO W
CONFUSED.
BRENDAN: THAT SHOT ALK.
TO THOMAS.
OUT HIGH.
THE BLAST.
S AND THEY A
GETTING A LO
ROBIN LEHNER IS OFF
TO A GOOD START.E
ICING AND PARAYKO
SKATES AHEAD REBOUND,
THEY SCORE.
THE PASS WAS PERFECT
BUT THE REBOUNJAKE WAL
MARCHESSAULT.
SIDE-TO-SIDE THERE
BUT LOOK WHAT
HAPPENS.
A QUICK
COUN
TIMING.
PASS FORCED ON.
GOT AWAY.
NOTCH.
BRENDAN: THAT ONE
OVER.
TARASENKO, A BURST
OF SPEED.
HE'S GOT NWAS NICOLAS .
NOT IN FRONT OF HIM.
PROBABLY AN
OPPORTUNITY ON THE  PA
HOW TO
HE'S GOT A LIGHTNING
QUICK GLOVE HAND BUT
IT L
OF REAL ESTATE,
DROPPED IT OUT FORNG F
PLAY AND GETS THAT
RIGHT OVER THERE TO
SAAD.NG
THE EFFECTS OF THAT
BLUES TRY TO TAKE --
LET'.
BRENDAN: KOLESAR
TRIED TO FEED IT.
COULD NOT BEBEICK
BUT LET'S KEEP OUR
EYE ON PIETRANGELO.R I
JENNIFER'S FATHER WAS THE SPORTS
PSYCHOLOGIST.
LESCHYSHYN.
SECOND GENERATION NHLer.
DARREN: AS THIS GAMEBINNINGTON.
BRENDAN: LOOK OUT,
ASIDE.
PIETRANGELO.
FOREHAND.
AND THE BIG BODIES,
TURNED BACK AROUND.
KYROU IN FRONT AND
THEY SVE THE ONE TOUCH
PASS.DOWN.
BRENDAN: THEODORE TO
ROY, THAT SHOT
THAT SHOT BY ROY AND
IT MAKES FOR A
ROBERT THOMAS COMING
WIDE.
THOMAS, CENTERS,
FOR CH PASS.
OBVIOUSLY AN EASY